time could be ticking for Homeland
Security secretary Alejandro mayorcas as
the crisis at the border spirals out of
control senior House GOP leaders
leadership tells Fox News a mayorcas
impeachment vote could come as early as
Tuesday Fox News National correspondent
bill malan is on the southern border
with an update on the border
crisis good evening we often hear about
child trafficking here at the border but
rarely do we actually get to see it take
a look at this harrowing Texas DPS video
one of their Troopers working Solo in
Kenny County pulls over a human Smuggler
and a known gang member whose car was
filled up with illegal immigrants he was
smuggling as the troopers arresting him
those illegal immigrants start bailing
out of the vehicle and running off into
the brush One By One The Trooper then
opens up the trunk and finds two
unaccompanied children ages seven and
nine both from Mexico being smuggled in
the back of that trunk now you'll notice
none of those people who bailed out of
the vehicle went for those little kids
that's because none of them are adult
adults guardians or relatives these two
little children were being smuggled with
a gang member and unknown adult men who
knows what would have happen to them if
Texas DPS didn't rescue them there is an
impeachment vote on DHS secretary my
orcus next week in the house and Jim
Jordan says he plans to vote Yes I would
support it uh I mean I think I think
this guy's done just a pathetic job and
we know the mlion come we have to hold
them accountable and I will be
supporting that privilege resolution to
impeach my orcus because frankly this
guy is a part of that problem and Texas
DPS says since the start of operation
lonar in 2021 they have rescued more
than 900 children in human smuggling
events we'll send it back to
you all right guy uh I want to play this
sound bite from Mike Johnson the new
speaker of the house because I there's
some politics at play here let's let's
play this sound bite from Mike Johnson
explaining what his thoughts are on
doing
impeachment it's inexcusable what he's
done I believe he's committed
impeachable offenses but we only have so
much time and resources to go after that
yeah that last line there only have so
when we think impeachment we think in
investigation an inquiry a committee
vote and March up what's happening now
is my representative Marg Taylor green
has put in what's called a um uh a
resolution um privilege of privilege and
the parliamentarian has said you meet
the prerequisites to put this at the
front of line what do you think the
politics are here are they really going
to impeach secretary morus they might
impeach him I doubt he'll be removed
from his post cuz he'd be protected in
the Democrat controlled Senate I think
it is self-evident that the situation at
the border is and has been now for
several years a National Disgrace it is
absolutely pathetic it is inexcusable
the lies and the gaslighting from this
secretary the excuses that he's making
the counterattacks that are nonsensical
I've had it up to here with him long ago
and so I'm totally in favor of throwing
him out of the job if that's possible
which I don't think it is the bigger
problem though is let's say by some
miracle he is removed then what it's
still Biden's policy he deserves as a
figurehead I think to get the boot
because of his job performance but if
you don't change the policy it's going
to be more the same Anita just looking
at the numbers cuz I mean the comment
there was he has done things that I
believe are inexcusable and impeachable
just looking at the numbers real quick
1.5 million getaways uh since Biden took
office 23,000 since October and then
we've got another graphic here that
shows kind of a yearly breakdown of
who's on the terror watch list do you
see where the numbers change look at
fiscal year 19
023 Biden comes into office where you
jump up to 15 and now 169 it seems like
that is some sort of a der elction of
Duty to the security of our country well
you know Joey I think those numbers
right there are the scariest part of all
of this I mean you know 600,000 uh
illegal immigrants uh have crossed the
border and gotten away since last year
but those numbers of those on the
suspected Terror watch list are the
scariest given the times that we're in
so it's going to be interesting to see
what happens on Tuesday if they when
they do this vote um and then yeah what
happens to him if they do vote to
impeach do listen watching that video
makes me viscerally upset uh to guys's
point if you spend a lot of time and
money on this removing mayorcas right
now is going to do nothing Republicans
need to focus on getting the 2024
presidential seat Democrats outspend
Republicans two to one they need to
focus on that and they need to focus on
Law and Order Texas is trying to do that
they're trying to actually make it
illegal to illegally cross the border
but of course the Biden White House will
not allow that to happen because it's a
federal issue they need to focus on 2024
with without impeachment I'd love a
secure border hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else